the villain kids they're heroes now Oh
Kenny we know this story isn't really
over just yet sure you guys might lay
low for a few years or so but there will
come a day when news of descendants for
horses through the world or at least
that's what we're hoping for but here's
the thing Kenny Ortega we never once
thought you'd make a High School Musical
4 and yes you are so anything is
possible as long as descendants fans are
patient but d3 fans aren't the only ones
who are having a hard time letting go of
the magical world of war Don and all of
its inhabitants some d3 stars have
shared some thoughtful words while
reacting to the ended The Descendants
franchise keep watching to find out why
Sophia Carson is so thankful for evey my
mom always says that friends or the
family that we choose and I think that
is exactly who the decays are booboo
Stewart during Disney's that's a rap
video booboo spoke out about having made
lifelong friends throughout the last
five years of his life and he also
opened up about being super proud to be
part of the descendents family and
despite not always posting about
descendents on his Instagram booboo
posted a picture of the core for joining
hands together booboo thanked all his
fans for the love they've shown him
stating that Friday August 2nd would be
an emotional day for everyone
Chyna and MacLean without uma the
descendents franchise would be missing
one of its biggest players china anne
mcclain gave us the uma we all deserved
and we totally love her for it this is a
job for pirate saying goodbye to the
descendents has been tough on the
actress especially after losing a
beloved cast member Chyna posted a few
pictures of the d3 cast on her Instagram
in this video we see her hugging her
fellow DK Carlos and laughing as he
whispered something in her ear according
to China this movie is for him and we
can't help but agree
Mitchell hope when it came to the king
of auradon he chose to keep things
simple
Mitchell hope posted a picture of King
Ben Queen mal
J and Carlos gazing over a balcony he
kept things short and sweet by stating
that it's been a ride but Mitchell
opened up a little more while filming
the Disney that's a wrap special
Mitchell said that he got to learn how
to be on set with the descendants cast
so they'll be friends for life
Sarah Jeffery Sarah posted a string of
pictures on her Instagram before d3 was
a release she was counting down for the
big reveal on Saturday August 3rd Sarah
posted a thoughtful tribute saying that
she was filled with so many emotions she
felt gratitude love sadness grief and
happiness for all the things she had
gained and the dear friend that she had
lost at the end of her post Sarah
thanked everyone for having given her
half a decade of pure magic Brenna D
amico Brennan posted a video of the d3
cast singing along to boom Shakalaka on
her Instagram page she wrote a
thoughtful post which said that the last
five years have been a dream come true
Brenna also stated that she would
forever cherish the time she spent with
her descendants family and like many
other d3 cast members Brenna dedicated
the three quilter on-screen lover Carlos
still in play fair Dylan took a page out
of Brenda's fairy tale book by posting
the same boom Shakalaka video on his
Instagram on Friday August 2nd
Dylan stated that today was the day that
all their hard work paid off
he revealed that descendants was one of
the most rewarding experiences of his
life I'm a star see that he also said
that he made some memories with the cast
that he would cherish for the rest of
his life
Cheyenne Jackson a tease also found the
time to drop some kind words during
Disney's that's a rap video according to
the actors The Descendants franchise is
very very special and he feels so
honored for having been welcomed into
its folds with open arms Cheyenne just
couldn't wait to see the entire project
come together on the small screen Kenny
Ortega working with director Kenny
Ortega is a dream come true for the
entire descendants cast Kenny is a
legend to me
it's crazy that I'm working with him and
as it turns out the famous director
couldn't be more pleased with what the
cast has accomplished Kenny also stated
that he's made a lot of friends so
saying farewell to the cast will be
super tough stop Cameron stop Cameron
truly gave us some out we didn't know we
needed she was fierce brave kind and
everything the people of auradon could
have wanted in a clean table posted a
behind-the-scenes video on Instagram and
captioned it with a long thank you note
in this note dub thanks kenny ortega for
everything he has given her while
expressing gratitude to her descendants
family stuff said goodbye to the
descendants franchise while stating that
she would forever be grateful for the
magical world it gave her Sofia Carson
instead of addressing the descendants
cast as a whole
sopia chose to pay Evie some tribute she
dedicated her entire Instagram post to
Evy saying that she couldn't bring
herself to say goodbye to her we each
walked into an audition room Sofia said
that being cast as Evie painted her
world in a beautiful shade of blue but
most of all Sofia is thankful for Evie
because she allowed her to meet her
Carlos which is more than she could have
ever hoped for so how do you guys feel
about the descendants franchise coming
to an end sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to the dings thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]